- Hey, folks, hope you're
all having a great day.
So it's been a very buzzing morning.
I think there are a lot
of sessions going around.
Just to give a quick introduction.
I'm Ananth and I'm part of the
leadership in ManageEngine,
which is one of the major
divisions in Zoho Corporation.
Today I'm here to talk about
one of the most important
and engaging aspects that
impacts the day-to-day operations
of most of the modern-day
digital businesses.
And that's nothing but AI,
so at the end of the day.
But here's the interesting part,
it has two sides.
So it has two sides, two perspectives.
And only when you kind
of bring them together
and introspect a lot more on that,
you'll get the real value out of it.
So let me not begin with
the definition to bore you,
but with a question.
If AI is the watcher, who
is really watching AI?
So this has been stayed
with me for quite some time.
If you look at the systems,
like there are so many
booths running here,
so many networking done over here.
They're no longer small or simple.
It's pretty clear. So what did we do?
Like we handed over some of the jobs to AI
to maybe detect the
anomalies that are happening
with maybe a Wi-Fi connection problem
across any sort of a booth.
And even fix them to certain extent,
like automate them in
an autonomous manner.
But on the hindsight, on the
flip side, if you look at this,
what happens if the AI itself goes wrong?
So that is something that is
kind of a lot more interesting
and when it does, in
most of the situation,
it doesn't give you a very
big alarming red flag and all.
It fails very quietly.
So this is the reason we
always think about this part
in ManageEngine and a lot of
products across the ecosystem
and we keep introspecting.
And I wanted to share my thought process
on both the sides of the story.
So on one side, it'll be
more on how observability
is powered by AI and how it
helps us to manage the chaos
and on the other side,
how observability for
AI itself is required
and it's more crucial
so that we can keep AI itself in check.
On the due process,
I will try to share some exciting stories
or usual stories that you
would've already heard
but closer to AI part,
I'll try to present my thought process
and take this as engaging as possible.
So let me just rewind for a moment.
I think that we have a
lot of veterans over here,
so if you rewind yourself,
take yourself maybe a decade
or two back, monitoring was pretty simple.
So we had a set of monolithic applications
that got deployed in cluster set up
or grid set up in colocation data centers.
And you have networking that is done
across all the applications
and bytes being captured
and you used to record a lot of things
so that whenever there is a problem,
you get the root cause analysis
from the monitoring solutions
and you kind of go towards
it, try to figure out
what is the problem and we
kind of sometimes take the logs
and debug it and fix it and life moved on.
But if you look at the current scenario,
it is no longer this simple.
The reason being we have
multiple cloud providers
apart from AWS,
we have multiple cloud
providers with multiple regions,
and what is the problem
is like you are being
given the option to deploy
in just a click of a button.
And apart from this containerization,
you have thousands of
containers spawning up
and down on a random basis,
which sometime goes out of control.
And moving from here, you
have containers calling APIs
and the APIs are calling
other APIs in endless chains
in the agentic era.
And finally, you have a set of users
and behaviors of users
who leave the app the moment
it is spotted to be slow.
So if you consider this entire scenario,
it's no longer a system anymore,
it is more of like a jungle
that we are actually dealing with.
So full stack observability
is some sort of a solution
that we are trying to
figure out still to kind
of map this jungle.
And if you ask me whether we
can navigate this jungle easily
by creating more dashboards or more alerts
or more workflows, the answer
is going to be a big no.
It is going to be how
efficiently we use AI
to solve and automate this entire workflow
as much as possible.
So you see that there is a lot
of ecosystem-related
problem in this scenario,
but AI acts like a copilot.
So most of the people fail to
realize the fact it acts more
of like a copilot to the existing humans
in the observability ecosystem.
So it scans millions of
events that are going
to go across networks, end
user experience, servers,
applications and it scans
almost all the events,
correlate all those events together
and clusters those signals
and helps us to connect
the dots across every layer
in the application ecosystem.
And sometimes it even helps us to predict
what might break next.
So that's the most important aspect
that we actually rely on AI for.
So it is more of like
if you check out this
particular visualization,
it acts like a traffic control system
in case of the modern digital world.
There could be thousands of planes
that are actually flying across the sky.
You are facing a lot of
delays right now in flight
and there are a lot of
cancellations happening.
But if you look at AI, it
helps us to spot exactly
what are the flights that we
have to look into right now
to make sure we give a
convenient experience
to the customer at the end of the day.
So this could be a little
bit like a gibberish kind
of an example.
So I'll just give you an
AI-on-AI event routine
that happens on a routine basis
just before the re:Invent.
I've been driving here for a decade
so every time when I come here,
I see Black Friday
happening the week before.
So just imagine that you're
using an e-commerce app
and you are actually kind of
doing a promotional aspect,
like say you're doing a marketing campaign
for a discounted product,
say that is an (indistinct) premium
or a Omera Premium that is being sent out
for 50% off, who doesn't like it?
So a lot of users just come
in and bombard your app
and they all face a
single checkout problem
at some point of time
when the load is going
to be unimaginably huge.
So with traditional monitoring systems,
this situation could turn
out to be a big chaos.
So what you'll get
is like you'll have a
single pane of glass,
like it's a common word
and you'll have CPU memory
or API response team,
everything will be spiking up
and again, your operations team,
tensions will also be flying very high
and they'll be coming to a single desk
and they'll be collating all this data
but by the time they arrive at a solution,
you would've lost all those users
who are actually in a checkout process
and millions of dollars will be also out
of your bank balance
at the end of the day.
So what you got to realize
is like how can we do better
with AI-powered observability
in this scenario?
So with solutions
that actually have
AI-powered observability,
it kind of seamlessly brings together
all the events together,
correlates among itself
and gives you an efficient
root cause analysis
in a smaller timeframe.
So that is the most important aspect
because if you're doing
it all in a manual manner,
it takes a longer time
to uncover a problem
than you do it with AI.
So that's the best part you get from that.
And once you get the RCA,
maybe the RCA is kind of figuring out
to a normal broke query
that is routinely happening
or it can also kind of suggest
you capacity-related issues
and give you the suggestions
on how much you got to
provision appropriately
to get out of the situation.
But wait, so AI is doing
all these jobs for you
but what happens, the
root cause analysis itself
can drag you down to a
different problem statement.
So we used to face this more often.
So like we have seen
these problems happening
in our own production
ecosystem inside Zoho,
as well as ManageEngine.
Like, it'll give us a anomaly
or else a false prediction,
which takes our entire operation team
towards a completely different direction.
It's more of like a ghost hunting trial
if you look at the situation.
They will go towards one
particular problem statement.
And the scariest part here
is like when AI is failing,
it fails with utmost confidence.
It makes you believe
that I'm always right.
I think most of you folks
would've used ChatGPT
and you would've believed its responses.
On the hindsight, it's
a view, you may think
that you might have a different assumption
but you won't question
the assumption of ChatGPT
because it's having huge
amount of data to work on
to give you the right answer,
so you keep believing in that scenario.
So imagine this side of the story as well.
So I use a lot of weather apps,
so on a routine basis I
rely on it to book meetings
and go across zones to
actually meet customers.
So just imagine that I need
to go to New York right now.
So there's a huge snowfall
happening in New York,
so it is a given event.
Say I plan about this almost
a week ahead right now
and I am planning to go to New York
in the December, third week.
My weather app states that there
is not going to be any sort
of a snowfall that is going to
happen in New York right now.
So the problem here is
like I take a flight,
I go and land, I make a
check-in and wait for two
or three days to meet my customer
but suddenly, there is a huge snowfall
and there is a pile of snowfall
that is getting piled up
and there are missions that are trying
to actually clear the
snowfall problem for you.
So my entire week is gone just
without meeting the customer
because they cannot come out,
I cannot get to their place
and that is a pretty much like
a very big problem statement.
Now, if you think, whether
the weather app is wrong,
no, the weather app has been in use
for more than a couple of decades.
I cannot question it but the
problem here is like the model
that is used to forecast
this weather pattern
could have gone without any update
or else just consider the API
that the weather app itself relies on
to actually collect the
data, to update the model.
Maybe that has gone out of service.
All these details are
actually kind of hidden gems
or hidden dragons which
do not get uncovered
in most of the scenarios.
And this is where we
could go for observability
for AI search.
So what do I mean by
observability for AI search?
Just like we monitor the CPU memory,
all those infrastructure-related metrics
to make sure that everything is healthy
and it is in sanity, we have
to actually have a close eye
or a third eye on top
of all the AI-related workflows
and its behaviors on a continuous manner.
If AI is part of your tech stack,
you need to have same level of visibility
and data collection that
you have already had
for a existing tech stack all the time.
So how do we do this?
Now, I will just take you
through a classic example
of how we do
infrastructure-based auto scaling
nowadays in most of the scenarios.
Just consider that you
have an operations team
and it has actually created a blueprint
for doing auto-scaling that is AI driven
for your entire Kubernetes ecosystem.
And they have run
this AI-driven auto
scaling multiple times.
It is bulletproof, stress tested
for multiple overnight scenarios.
Your operations team has been
loaded with a lot of work
for the entire Black Friday.
They're kind of exhausted
and they want to take
a Thanksgiving weekend
without taxing them off.
So what they do
is like they turn on this
auto scaling mode button
and enable this blueprint
and they go on a vacation
for those couple of days.
All of a sudden, at some
particular point, you see that lot
of resources get provisioned
by this auto scaling mode
and it is due to some sort of a pattern
that is being misread by
AI to be considering it
to be an auto scaling scenario.
And this particular spike,
if you consider this pattern,
sometimes there could be periodic spikes
that happens within a
particular hour itself.
So that is a concept
in the cloud ecosystem
where if you rotate the
resources on a continuous basis
within a particular hour,
you get charged for the entire hour.
So what happens here
is like say there are 10 auto
scaling incidents happening
within an hour and it continues
to happen for 48 hours,
you're going to end up with
500 auto-scaling events
within the time your
operation team gets back
on a Monday morning.
So they'll be staring at a huge
cloud bill and I pity them.
So what we could have done
differently with observability
for AI over here.
So we could have identified
this anomaly detection pattern
by the AI-based auto
scaling system earlier
and we could have merged this context
with traditional monitoring data
to actually consider this
to be a sustained peak
in most of the scenarios.
And we could have provisioned systems
that could run on a permanent basis
and at the end of the day, we
could have saved a lot more
on your cloud bill.
So this takes us to the
heart of the subject.
So measuring what really matters
is going to be the agenda
that you gotta have when
you're taking both sides
on AI-powered observability
and observability for AI.
The first side is more
of the classic ones,
which is going to be more
of observability metrics,
CPU memory, already have
repeated all those things,
you already know about all those things.
And this helps us to make sure
that the system is healthy
and available all the time.
The second part is something
that is going to be new
that you got to be a lot
more interested about.
It's going to be the
drift prediction rate,
confidence levels and last
but not the least, cost.
So these metrics will help us to make sure
that we can continue trusting
AI for making the decisions
for us and we should also
consider another fact
where at scale whether
AI will run at a rate
which we consider to be a sustainable one.
So sustainability is one more
thing that we need to consider
as a factor in case of AI world.
This is one of the
reasons why we always feel
that FinOps is one of the
major players in the AI world
as we all know that we are never blessed
with infinite budgets.
Now, only when you bring these two sides,
I spoke about two different parts together
as part of a single coin
or maybe consider these
two different aspects
as a single entity,
you'll begin to see the
real value out of it.
So if you check out
AI-powered observability,
it gives us speed, scale, and foresight
in most of the situations.
And observability for AI gives us trust,
reliability and accountability.
And together you actually kind
of get the full picture of observability
and it gets completed when
you consider both the sites
because going forward,
it's never going to be
about infrastructure and
applications alone anymore.
It's going to be infra, applications
and AI that unifies them into
a single intelligent system.
This is the reason, like
we have followed this
as an expectation at ManageEngine
and we have built our item suite
with this exact thought process.
We use AI to seamlessly integrate
and correlate all the signals
across applications, users
and infrastructure in order to reduce
or cut the noise for the enterprises
and help them focus on
exactly what's needed
with a comprehensive suite of solutions
that is going to be more
than like 60 plus products
with complete focus on solving
or covering all the aspects
of enterprise IT management.
With an integrated suite, we
follow a holistic approach
to AI adoption where we kind
of mix all the distress signals
from across the ecosystem
and we create a value in a unified manner.
So let me leave you with this
thought process for the day:
future of observability is not going
to be about humans versus AI,
it's going to be more about
humans working with AI
as active enablers.
At the end of the day, we
all know that we cannot fix
what we don't measure,
and AI is going to need the help of humans
to measure what's really needed.
So hope you got some valuable
sort of information today.
Thanks for coming over.
I'd be more than happy to meet you guys
in our ManageEngine
booth, which is at 147.
Have a great week ahead.